as Battin s'en been outfitted
rumor-mongering website we got this
covered a website mind you whose Intel
should be taken with a grain of salt is
reporting that sources have gotten a
peek at the duds Robert Pattinson will
wear in the upcoming the Batman and if
their report is accurate it'll be a
version of the bat suit quite unlike any
we've seen on screen before why is he
wearing this custom from the movie he
did 24 years ago he wore the outfit from
clean and sober no no not that one this
latest report falls in line with other
independently reported rumors that the
Batman will be based at least loosely on
the JEP lopen limited series the long
Halloween published between 1996 and
1997 and featuring art by comics great
Tim sail the series is set in the early
days of the Dark Knight's crime-fighting
career and features bats shaking down
Gotham's criminals while investigating a
series of brutal murders according to
the report Pattinson Batsuit will
feature a look very similar to the one
sail created for the long Halloween
we're talking a gray suit with traces of
black with a large black bat emblem on
the chest a big billowy blue cape of the
blue cowl and very long pointy ears we
can't say for sure whether this rumor is
accurate but it does stand to reason
that the look for Pattinson spat suit
would have been completed recently sure
he screen-tested in costume before
landing the role but it's likely that
the suit used for his test was from a
previous production which is par for the
course for superhero reboots the Batman
will be going before the cameras very
soon so it's likely that its iteration
of the bat suit is at least close to
being finalized the Batman writer
director Matt Reeves has gone on record
stating that his film won't be a
straight adaptation of any one story
from the comics but based on what he
himself has said about it it certainly
seems like the long Halloween will be a
heavy influence Reeves has said that the
flick will be a noir ish Gritti tail and
we know that it will feature a pretty
extensive rogues gallery of classic
Batman villains with zoe kravitz playing
Catwoman Paul Dano portraying the
Riddler and Colin Farrell and stalks to
play the penguin that checks two boxes
right off the bat and earlier this year
the rumor mill turned forth another
nugget that the Batman will see the
Caped Crusader investigating a series of
ghastly killings plaguing Gotham if this
turns out to be accurate and Reeves
continues to insist that his movie isn't
an adaptation of any existing Batman
story then we're going to have to go
ahead and state that that director is
full of it at any rate it would be
pretty cool to get a more comics
accurate depiction of the Batsuit the
dark knights looked in previous movies
has always been pretty cool but let's
face it no previous version has had much
of a resemblance to anything we've seen
in the comics pages this suckled stop a
knife bullet proving anything but a
straight shot why didn't they put it
into production bean-counters didn't
think a soldier's life was worth 300
grand from Tim Burton's Batman to
Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy
movie Batman's costume has always
resemble tactical body armor modified to
look like a bat suit more than anything
else particularly due to the fact that
the Batman will be giving us an earlier
less experienced version of the Caped
Crusader we'd really like to see
something more in line with the classic
blue and gray color scheme that DC fans
loved one could make the argument that
such a getup would be a touch too
reminiscent of Adam West's bat suit from
the campy 60s television series but we
would counter that Hollywood costume
designers are paid gobs of money to make
superheroes look awesome on screen so we
probably need not worry too much about
that
we'll see how it all shakes out in a
year and a half or so when the flick
comes flapping into theaters on June
25th 2021 check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff or
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]